the jurogan experience the big change in
my life was when i learned how to
breathe i started bringing more
spiritual possibilities more mental
possibilities
because what is interesting about the
the breathing aspect is
the brain
and the in the heart
are the only organs
who can give and receive information
there are the organs liver kidney they
don't cannot do that but when you get
upset with something mentally you bring
information to yourself immediately your
brain is responding your heart to when
you get depressed immediately you feel
in your heart
and your heart show you
you said show you is immediately
connection
and what is amazing about that is the
lung
is the practical aspect within you
who are able to control or help your
your brain and also help your heart
so through the proper breathing you can
control your heartbeats
through the proper breathing you can
control your mindset and get calmer
control your panic control your courage
control everything you need in the
mental aspect and also spiritual hope
faith
visualizations
so all the elements in your brain
all the elements in your heart can be
much better guidance much better helped
through the lungs
if you don't know how to involve your
lungs in your breath
in your breathing
you you're not able to
to to favor your your brain and your
heart the way it's supposed to be
it's kind of amazing that everybody
breathes but
a relatively small percentage of people
know how to breathe correctly yes
you born you got slapped on your butt
and you think you live in well and you
breathe for life
it's not like that
the first learning you learn
about breathing is to move the upper
body the upper part of your lung
if you don't learn if you don't practice
you're never going to use the
diaphragmatic breathing which
involves the full capacity of your lungs
so the diaphragm when you learn how to
move your diaphragm efficiently
you fill up your lungs in a different
way
so if i breathe right
or wrong
either more or less oxygen up to me the
way i use the diaphragm or not
so when i learn how to use that i'm able
to help my body and whatever needs
mental spiritual or physical
when you uh that famous scene in choke
when you're moving your stomach around
or the drums beating it's it's really
crazy i love people people love that
scene yeah because you're using
that control of your diaphragm
how did you learn how to do that
the orlando he taught you how to do that
yes
and how long did it take before you
could move your stomach like that it's
not as difficult too right yeah it's not
as difficult you can learn this in no
time you just need the right instruction
because
it's all about
is it's a quick learning you know it's
just you have to put some attention
because when you learn how to breathe
you start adding oxygen you to your life
you can stay five seven days without
food five days without water but five
minutes without the air you're dead
so when you know how to hyperventilate
it's like it's double your life triple
your lifetime because you're not get
tired as well when you say
hyperventilate what do you mean by
hyperventilate i'm here come right
if i do this
i breathe
if i want to go dive
i need to hyperventilate
so i need to
because i increase the circulation of
oxygen
in my body and i increase the blood the
oxygen on the cells
so i do hyperventilation for a little
while and i triple the amount of time i
gonna be under the water
another important thing for people to
learn about breathing is
the idea of inhale
the inhale
is not the cause it's the solution
so what i what if i need a full lung a
full breath
i don't want to just do
if i want a full breath i first need to
now
i have a full breath because if i just
start from here
i already have 30 of the air inside
which is not it doesn't empty enough so
in order for me to
put it all in 100 of good air inside
my liveness
my attention has to be on the exhale
now i'm ready to get there
the effort
the strength on the muscle if i need to
be get a big biceps
i need to curl
if i need to have a strong breathing
system i need to exhale
they inhale
it's natural
some people they feel tired i need their
they go against the
and against the the flow
because they try to bring in which is
already claustrophobic
more i need air more like
oh my god
so my liveness my focus is to take the
bad gas out of me
the good gas coming naturally
some people say i need a they need air
but they're already full of bad gas um
so and that's make a big confusion on
the
on the right way to the gas community
out so my organization and my brain is
to put the bad gas out of me
so when i training consistently i choose
if i'm not effective on the exhale i'm
not going to be effective on an inhale
and the liveness of my my muscle system
is the contraction
the contraction is the diaphragmatic
breathing
there's a contraction
if i do a curve for getting strong
biceps that's the contraction
when i do this i relax
contract
so contrast relax
so and that's give me a different edge
to understand clearly everything around
me watch the entire episode for free
only on spotify